at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking the oils working for now is the
type of medical organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash Tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest eight thirty
thousand dollar account for instant
now normally when I have a sponsor on
the show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
fast free there's no downside that I can
think of this episode is brought to you
by athletic greens I've used athletic
greens for many many years and I'm asked
all the time if you could use only one
supplement what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is my all in one nutritional
insurance at least that's how I think
about it it is much more than greens
it's a complete whole food supplement
with 75 or so ingredients packed into
one tablespoon per day so when I travel
for instance of course I would like to
follow all of my regimens all of my
pills all of my cell phones all of my
food to the tea but sometimes
circumstances intervene and you're too
busy or things are too hectic this helps
me to mitigate the likelihood of getting
sick and to perform optimally so if I go
to say South America for an AcroYoga
intensive which I did in Colombia at one
point I was running around like a
chicken with its head cut off and I took
this every morning and it is extremely
extremely helpful and I usually travel
with travel packets among other things
so you should try it out is the short
version of this as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive $100 worth
of travel packs for free when you order
that's 20 free additional individual
travel pouches when you order simply go
to athletic greens dot-com forward slash
Tim to check it out so
Oh take a look at what agreeance calm /m
hello my friendly lady Mogwai this is
comparison welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show where it is typical
my job to deconstruct world-class
performers this episode is a little
indirect because the questions come from
you Arnold Schwarzenegger is back for a
round two on the podcast that could not
be more excited in our first
conversation which is episode 61 of my
most popular of all time the former mr.
Olympia Terminator and governador shared
lessons learned daily routines
psychological warfare tactics which were
amazing favorite books early
entrepreneurial ventures and tips for
instance I made millions in real estate
before he had his movie break meditation
and many stories known in heard before
this time around the new host of the
Celebrity Apprentice answered your most
popular and uploaded questions including
some controversial questions he does not
shy away from anything and this is no
exception he does not mince words in
this episode among other things
Arnold talks about his recent Twitter
battle with president-elect Donald Trump
his investment strategies politics the
state of bodybuilding his sleep schedule
and many more never before told stories
he did however forget to plug his latest
project so I will do it here tune into
the new Celebrity Apprentice Mondays at
8 p.m. or watch it on the NBC app I hope
you enjoyed this incredible round 2 with
Arnold Schwarzenegger I promise that it
does not disappoint the first question
comes from Tim Ferriss he wanted to lead
off with a lot has been written about
the president elects use of Twitter his
tweets had moved the stock market and
defined the news of the day you were
recently on the receiving end of a
couple of his tweets I think your
response said it also I don't want to
reopen it but I would like to hear about
the process how did you react when you
heard he had tweeted about you and how
did you formulate your mic drop response
well first of all let's just kind of
create the atmosphere here you're
sitting outside here outside my house
the fire is on the outdoor fireplace I'm
smoking my stogie and we're having a
great time the jacuzzi is warming up
slowly said that afterwards we can take
a jacuzzi and so on so that's number one
number two let's get now to add and to
this very important question that Tim
has a great question first of all it is
important when you want to respond that
you don't respond immediately
did you don't respond with a with you
emotion because of course you go through
various different stages you know the
figures if I would have responded right
away I would have said don't go into a
stinking contest with a skunk but then a
cinema said well maybe that's not the
right answer and it really doesn't say
anything so let me wait a little bit
then I said to myself well you know I
think actually I expected that tweet
because I tweeted out I did I'm not
going to vote for him and I encourage
other people not to vote for him says
Evers if you know being down with Trump
I probably I would have done the same
thing just ant you know tweet back so
that was to be expected so now it was
just an audio answer back and then
slowly but surely you know I started
developing different events with
different stages and I said to myself at
one point in oh maybe I should just go
back east and just you know hit his head
against the table or something like that
there's something that is stupid
okay let's get out of that one and so
eventually I came up with something that
was you know where I talk about look
this is in a lot of energy that he put
in there to compete about the ratings
and whether who is better ratings Norris
I hope did he put the same amount of
energy into serving all the people of
America because it's a really important
job to do the president and you have to
be able to serve both Democrats and
Republican and declined to stay staid
and independents and everybody and so he
should put that his energy into that so
that's how I came up with that basically
great
so jandi Wiegand or maybe yon
said what was the hardest choice in your
life and what was the biggest sacrifice
you've made while climbing the ladder of
success I think that there's no two ways
about it that the toughest choice was to
give my bikini wax before Conan the
Barbarian no I I think you know
definitely the toughest choice was to
run for governor because I really felt
very passionate about becoming a public
servant and I felt really strongly that
I could do a better job than the
politicians in Sacramento I felt that
the politicians screwed up the state
that's why we black out said why we had
huge debt and deficits and no one could
get along Democrats and Republicans
couldn't work together and it was just a
huge mess here and I felt that I could
do a better job as a but at the same
time I recognized the fact that I just
finished Terminator and Terminator 3
came out and I this is I became the
highest-paid actor at that time in the
world and so that meant that I was not
going to be able to make two movies a
year and make this kind of millions and
billions of towers so am I willing to go
and walk away from all that money
potentially over 100 million dollars
over the next you know seven years and
so then there was the family question
you know my wife was not very
enthusiastic about it she comes from a
family that had power exceda tremendous
impact on death on the family and side
effects and so she felt like the same
would happen to our family instead of
all of those debates but eventually
after long deliberation and thinking
about the whole thing I did make up my
mind and they decided to do it but it
was a very very tough decision to make
because I had to think about all those
different aspects and but I went for it
and if a very bad day after made the
decision I was 100% behind it and I felt
like I had a need to serve the people
and to give back to this great great
country that gave me everything Rachel
or Rachelle wind holes asked what is the
mole
important thing a woman needs to know if
she wants to lead both men and women
effectively well I think that the first
thing she needs to do is you take out
the as a woman because if you want to be
a leader you know you got to think of
yourself as a person as a human being
and others a woman was a man but just
you know paint a great vision of where
you want to go what is your goal and
then that clear vision that you share
with everyone men and women around you
will follow you because of the
enthusiasm and because you have a very
clear vision and you would inspire them
so being inspirational and having a
clear vision having a clear goal and
rally everyone behind you I think is the
most important thing but don't think of
yourself as a woman in this case because
I tell you Indira Gandhi did not think
of herself as a woman when she led India
I think that mrs. Thatcher who was
successfully leading England did not
think of herself as a woman and oh my
god what would it be like now as a woman
to lead the England or something like
that mrs. Gordon Mayo was one of the
most extraordinary leaders of Israel and
let this great country through the 67
war against so many different countries
was highly successful did not think of
herself I bet you any money as a woman
you know
Chancellor Merkel who is one of the
greatest you know leaders in Germany
right now who has been a long an office
I think than anyone else very
effectively that is a woman I don't
think she sees herself as a woman as a
matter of fact I remember when I met her
several times during the time I was
governor you know she was a tough leader
really good spot because smartly in
history me politics will be economically
with all the different issues but she's
never even come up to subject though I'm
a woman and as a woman I do this and
that and so on
imagine Catherine the Great when she led
Russia man do you think that she thought
of herself as will say you know I think
take that out completely the woman stuff
and just see yourself as a person and as
someone that is a great leader with a
great vision and invaluable behind you
this reminds me you've talked before
about wanting to bring women's body
building and
Arnold Classic is this the same
philosophy that you didn't want him to
think of themselves as women well it's a
little different because I think that
there is still a tremendous prejudice
towards women and what women should not
do and I feel that through sports I have
learned that we are all equal and that
women should have the same right to do
the same sport those guys two guys
should have the same right to the same
sports women do and so I felt like who
is to say that bodybuilding is a male
thing that no women can also build their
bodies with maybe differently but let
them decide how they want to do it but
let women compete in bodybuilding
competitions so we started with Harold
Schneider I remember back east we
started in Pennsylvania we started the
first Miss Olympia competition and then
we moved to Columbus and behaved in
Columbus Ohio at our competition it
combined with mr. Olympia and mr.
universe that the Miss Olympia and then
it became highly successful and now
women bodybuilding and women fitness and
training and all this stuff is as much a
part of the international bodybuilding
scene as for the male body builders
Joseph Darrell rod asked Arnold have you
always slept so sparingly or do you
purposely sleep less to gain extra hours
in your day what's your current league
schedule like and how do you keep high
energy with little sleep well my current
sleeping is schedule is pretty much the
same has been for the last few years I
get up early in the morning and then I
go and work out right the bicycle for an
hour and take a shower have breakfast
you know feed my dogs play with my dog
call my kids tell them I love them and
read a script or to read the papers in
English and in German also and and at
that time it's around five o'clock in
the morning okay what's your actual
morning routine
but the bottom line is is that I have
slept nine hours a day when it was 19
years old because at that point when I
was younger I needed more sleep and I
woke up nine hours later and that took
my nine hours and got the four nine
hours of sleep as time went on I'm used
less and less sleep and now it doesn't
matter where I am I wake up
six hours after I go to sleep it doesn't
mean six hours after go to bed because
there's a lot of people that have
trouble getting to sleep and there's
another secret that I use and that is I
don't have my iPhone or my iPad or
anything in the bedroom
I do not an hour before or two hours
before get into some heavy kind of
debates about business and stuff like
that
or accept phone calls where those kind
of things can happen because I've seen
that then then you go to bed and your
mind keeps going and going and going and
doesn't allow you to go to sleep so it's
important to not do that there's other
people that are very successful by not
even watching TV and it just read a book
or something like that and that puts
them to sleep at that stand of that I
watch TV because that does not kind of
like part of me when I watch the news
and so on or make me think about it for
the next hour so so I can actually goes
off watching TV or reading something so
the key thing for me is you stay asleep
and then I wake up and that is usually
six hours five and a half hours
sometimes five hours sometimes six and a
half hours but it's an average of around
six hours it doesn't matter if I'm
flying to Europe on the plane that is
its fourth hour flight
sometimes I also wake up six hours later
after I go to sleep and in Europe with
the time change I get up six hours later
so it gives me an advantage of course
that I have extra few hours then to do
other things and to learn or to be to do
something that is fun to do but I mean I
think the peeps the key thing is for
people not to get as obsessed about the
sleep that you can carve out extra time
but to organize your day
really well so that you can do a lot of
things and accomplish a lot of things
rather than wasting the day if that's
what you want to do you know there's
people that say okay I'm retired I'm
just going to play golf and I don't even
pay any attention to being productive I
have done this my whole life
others want to be productive then I
would just say okay here's where they
get up the early risers usually are the
most successful people I think it's the
President of the United States if it is
the Pope over all the leaders all the
business leaders everyone always tells
me that they get up at five o'clock at
six o'clock they read the paper they get
going they get organized you know said
answering mail communicating with Europe
and stuff like that so I think it's
organizing your day and having a very
clear vision and program of what you
want to accomplish and be enthusiastic I
think that is the key thing not just to
worry about I got down asleep six hours
otherwise I'm losing too much time or
something like that house wise the best
thing is to get enough sleep that you
need everyone is a little bit different
about that Perri Reed asks what is
something you believe that others might
consider totally crazy I think the first
thing that comes to my mind is that you
can't protect the environment and
protect the economy at the same time and
we have seen this in California how
successful we have been when I was
governor I was very fortunate to lead a
state that had a great history in
protecting the environment but also has
a great history of you know being
economically a powerhouse we have been
consistently anywhere visit the fifth
largest economy to the eighth largest
economy in the world
now we gained the fifth economy in the
world and I think that just shows to you
that having a great environmental
protection and laws in place in
protecting the environment that you
can't do that successfully we have made
a commitment to reducing greenhouse
gases by 25 percent by the year 2020 we
have made a commitment to have almost 50
percent of renewables by the year 2020
we have made a commitment to make up
buildings more green and to have you
know to do things that really move cells
in the direction of keeping our
environment clean but at the same time
we have also proven that our GDP for
instance but the national GDP is a one
and a half two percent of growth we
encoded for Nia had a GDP growth last
year for instance of four point two
percent so as you can see that we are
doubled as good as the nation is as an
average and we have the strong strongest
and the toughest environmental laws at
the same time so there's a huge
misconception that going green means
that you destroy the economy and B if as
a matter fact the green sector in
California you know it produces ten
times more jobs now than any other
sector in California so no matter which
way you look you know we have become a
leader and to be at the fifth largest
economy in the world and we are doing at
the rest of the states in the United
States so I hope that the federal
government takes really close notice of
what California is doing
Patrick Chapman says I'm a musician
taking auditions and competitions
constantly I'd love to hear your best
tips for preparing mentally for
competition well I think that it doesn't
really matter if you're going to an
audition for music or for movies or TV
or if you're competing on a stage in the
bodybuilding competition or if you're
doing a downhill race as a skier or your
UFC fighter or if you run a corporation
it is mileage it is reps that count the
more often you do something I am a big
believer in practicing and practicing
and practicing why because the more you
practice the better you get the more it
becomes second nature and then slowly
the fear goes away that you may not be
able to remember your lines when you
focal for an audition or the fear that
you may be a sound stupid and that
you're not going to pull it off or
whatever it is it is always said that
more you practice something the more
confidence you get and the better you
got to perform when you go to those
auditions in the first place so reps
reps reps and just keep practicing and
practicing
we were saying in German even Martin
Meister which means you know the more
you practice something the more you
become the mass of something you know so
that's that's a reality is that why when
you have a near speech you're practicing
you write the calories on it well be
good that the tallies are right on
because that comes from my bodybuilding
and weightlifting background because we
used to have a talk in our weightlifting
gym and we've made a line for each rep
that we did so that I know on the end
when you look at it did I really do all
my sets rather than cheating on yourself
with your rep so with you said so with
anything else we even wrote the weight
on it next to it and compared it to the
last week's chart of how much we
improved on the weight notice so it is
all about always to do enough reps and
of course you learned this in sport this
is why I always say you know families
should insisted the kids to sports
because in sports we'll learn the
lessons there is no shortcut and the
only way you get confidence is by doing
reps and getting good at what you're
doing and that should give you the
confidence then you cut down the
failures and on and on and on so just do
the reps
Marcia Peterson acts in Arnold's
experience how does age and aging affect
diet and fitness what adjustments do you
recommend for those of us who are no
longer spring chicken well I think the
first thing that comes to my mind is you
get the really very adamant to use when
you get older organic gluten free Botox
I mean this is extremely important no in
all seriousness I think that the most
important thing really is is that you
recognize that your metabolism slows
down and let's say as a male they don't
produce as much testosterone and so
definitely have to take certain food
supplements that that you can supplement
and produce more testosterone and that
you eat
did you watch more the kind of food you
eat because what you get away with when
you're 19 to 20 years old
you're not going to get away with now I
remember that when I was competing in
the Miss Olympia competition and that
was at the height of my bodybuilding
career you know we worked at five hours
a day and the body was a much faster
metabolism we would go even before a
competition before the mr. Olympia
competition to the house of pies and we
we eat a pie and that the day I could
not get away with that because you would
immediately gain weight those days it
was before the competition we still won
the competition because your metabolism
is different so you have to recognize
that you have to go and stay away from
bread is to stay away from desserts
maybe can have it every so often but
don't think that is a daily routine
nature's keep eating bread and pasta and
you desserts and ice cream and all the
kind of things and I'd have to tell you
that this is very torturous for me
because I am Austrian and then generally
grow up in Austria with beautiful
wonderful desserts I mean it's from the
socket toward quesiton one after strudel
tub from strudel labor cleaners I mean
there's so many different things that we
have that they're fattening and they
gotta get off all of those things and
just really you know eat much lighter
I eat smaller meals now at night many
times they just have soup and nothing
anything and what did they release they
trim it is a real paddle and I think
that I'm not the only one that goes
through the battle I think everyone in
the gym and I go to gold shim at the
everyone tells me the same story then as
soon as they get to be past forty you
know and they have a tendency of getting
easier over weight and fat and now of
course it's a good time because it's new
year so you can make a new year's
resolution and say I want to lose ten
pounds so I want to lose twenty pounds
and here's the diet that I'm going to be
on and that's exactly what I would
recommend my Kunik says you have a great
history combating climate change and
you've recently taken on trying to get
people to eat less meat as animal
agriculture is a major source of
greenhouse gas emissions what are your
future plans to keep spreading this
message and reach more people well I
think that the most upsetting thing to
me is that
we have so many really passionate
environmentalist that really are serious
about helping the earth be healthy and
reducing pollution but their
communication skills are lousy because
they always keep talking about climate
change it doesn't matter what speech did
you listen to if it is President Obama's
speech or if it is some senators speech
over there some environmental speech
they talk about climate change and it
doesn't mean anything due to the mass in
the world it goes right over their head
and they talk about something that
happens in ten years from now they talk
about what happens in 20 years from now
and just sea levels rising in 50 years
from now and since they said the human
mind is not equipped to think down the
line what happens down the line they
want to know what's happening today
what's happening right now it was
happening right now it's disastrous
because pollution and that's what
environmentalist should be talking about
pollution is killing seven million
people a year that is happening right
now and they never talked about it as it
emissive what is going on with those
guys why are they so obsessed about you
know climate change and not about the
amount of people that are dying every
year because of pollution I mean the
amount seven million that I'm talking
about it's much more than all the
traffic accidents that's much more than
but is that the wars that Cuba people oh
that Isis says be worried about or
suicide or homicide so all these things
together is not even close to there's
not amount of seven million people so
pollution is the biggest killer and
they're not talking about it they kind
of throw it away yeah and it says this
kind of change and then it also that
helps aspect of it it's very you know
people get sick from pollution and order
should they mention it as a society bar
but not really as like the main thing
that's what's happening today so the
communication has to be better I always
talk about the four legged stool I
always talk about that yes we should
talk about climate change because that
is a reality we will have climate change
disease disasters but you know
really make people react and become part
of the of the environmental crusade we
should tell them that right now seven
million people die in America 250,000
people die and you know in India over a
million people in China over a million
people die because of pollution and this
goes on and on all over the world that's
what we should talk about
so the first leg should be in a climate
change second they should be that you
know talking about the pollution the
third should be that how many jobs we
can create with a green economy and the
forces national security so we should
visit the four legged stool because we
got to get energy independent because it
gives off fossil fuels so we don't have
to ever rely on countries that our enemy
and it wouldn't wish as well so it does
it this is a four legged stool that I
talked about and I think that is what we
need to concentrate on and we just have
to kind of let everyone know that they
got to communicate differently and
gather communicate in the way that mean
something to people they understand
because people are basically survivors
they worry about right now when you have
an accident you don't go and say this
they're thinking about when Jama breaks
the lake and they ever wound how are we
going to fix the lake no first you stop
the bleeding
that's the first thing that you do and
then you go and take them to the
hospital and then they can worry about
how to fix the leg and all those kind of
things and the same is with our
environmental movement we got to talk
about the amount of people to diarrhea
because of pollution and just to expand
on Mike's question this isn't just
theoretical for you you actually ran the
anti prop 23 campaign in California in
2010 with these principles well you're
absolutely correct because we found out
the total coincidence that this is what
the people really pay attention to the
most is to help aspect and it is you
know of what tremendous impact that
pollution has not only on the health of
grown-ups but for instance in the
Central Valley in California we talked
about you know how it creates asthma
asthma and both kind of effect it has on
kids and their health and suffocation
people were so alarmed when they heard
that the statistics that they did
everything they could to go in to keep
in effect our environmental laws even
though the oil and coal companies came
into California with proposition 23 and
tried to have the people vote against
our environmental laws and they were not
successful we beat them with 80 percent
of the votes and chased them out of the
state because we use the health aspect
as a means to really get through
independently through the people and let
them know how important is that we keep
our environmental laws which are the
best in the nation and our environmental
laws one and conservative districts as
well as liberal districts are right
that's right because if the Republicans
and Democrats alike all want to go and
have healthy air and have healthy water
clean water and a green ground I mean
the a of water pollution and the ground
pollution that we have is disastrous and
we got to always fight in order to clean
our environment
Cody Schuckman says Arnold we hear about
your many successes in life what do you
consider your greatest failure and how
to set up or shape your future successes
well I think that you have to recognize
that it doesn't matter who it is the
most successful person in the world can
tell you honestly the Delta has a
tremendous amount of failures it's not
always just success the key thing is is
that we learn from the failures actually
more than from our successes and it
doesn't matter if you talk about the
best you know basketball player I
remember Maggie Jordan want them said in
an interview that he missed 9000 shots
you know and he was one of the good the
greatest if not the greatest basketball
player in the world
so yes you miss and I remember that you
know Ted Williams one of the greatest
baseball players remember 1910 was 1941
or so when they here at the best of
baseball season and he averaged 406 406
and and that meant that forty percent
plus forty point six percent to be exact
he was successful with his hits there is
padding and
see percent therefore were failures so
think about it this is the greatest you
know a baseball player that this record
still stands today so it just shows you
that everyone has failures and
everywhere and so the key thing is is
that you learn from this field as we
move on I had my failures in
bodybuilding and lost bodybuilding
competitions most people only know my
victories which were a lot but that's
also lost I lost in weightlifting I lost
in powerlifting I embarrassed myself
many times trying to lift the 500 pounds
and the benchpress in front of 2,000
people in the beer hall in Germany and I
failed and it crashed in my chest they
couldn't make it but eventually it did
make it and I lost you know I had
failures in the movie business I
remember I saw the movies they went
through the roof but then there were
movies that went right in the toilet
that were not as successful books that
came out with dead one and we have Times
bestseller list and then others that
didn't you know live up to the
expectations and failed so yes we have
those kind of things and to me the key
thing is always and you know that we
learn from it I have failed as also I
remember in my personal life and I
learned from that you know and then you
move on again what is important is that
you get up when you fall the winner
always gets up and the loser stays down
that's what is it what's the difference
so to me the important thing is always
that when you've in you when you fail on
something you dust if you get up you
dust yourself off and you move on
and have again a great vision of which
direction you want to go pick another
goal and keep moving forward
Philip Charles asked what tip did you
receive and an older age that you could
have used in your 20s what does a lot of
things that we learned throughout the
years obviously but I think the main
thing that that comes to my mind is
charity you know that when you're young
don't think about that you should reach
out and you should help others so you
know like I was only thinking about my
goal to be on that stage at in London at
the Mr Universe competition and just
like reg Park my idol that once we miss
the universe competitions and then
became Hercules in the movies know that
I wanted to have the trophy on that same
stage as he wanted and that was the only
thing that in my mind then after I want
that it was winning with all and being
with the world and all the competition
becomes the greatest bodybuilder that's
all I had in my mind there was total
tunnel vision and but then later on I
learned luckily that how important it is
to also not only think about me but to
think about we and to go and to help
others that a lot of people they need
help if it is help people that need help
in their training and to go around and
help people hold seminars and teach them
about training and about the importance
of exercising the right way if it is
that to make sure that everyone can do
sports like I got involved in Special
Olympics instead of helping Special
Olympians to do sports and specifically
to the weight training and powerlifting
and they introduced into the Special
Olympics movement powerlifting
competitions which are now worldwide
they're very very successful
we started Special Olympics specifically
in Austria also and got older ski races
together to start in to help me and
support me in just as Special Olympics
then work together with the private
sector and the government notice and
then eventually you know I starting
after-school programs and then becoming
the chairman of the President's Council
on physical fitness and travel around
the countries for all 50 states and
promote health and fitness and bring
everyone together and then eventually
led to running for governor so I think
giving back and recognizing that every
one of us needs help I got plenty of
help to be where I am today there's no
such thing as a self-made man as I
always say you know there's people that
helped me to be where I am today
so it is up to me now to inspire other
people to help them and to go and reach
out and to help them this is what made
me
because involved in the environmental
movement and in this environmental
crusade and I just love giving back
where you don't think about what is in
it for me but you know how can I help
this great nation of America they gave
me all the chances in the world and it
opened up so many doors of opportunities
I would not have accomplished any of the
things if it wouldn't have come to
America and you know so to give
something back to me is extremely
important and I want to have kids learn
this as early as possible that part of
being successful is to give also
something back you talked about tunnel
vision Louis Lewis or Louie Congdon
says have you ever found that your
pursuit of success as many blind to
other parts of your life well I don't
know if you would call it blind but I
would say that yes when you are trying
to be successful you have to have tunnel
vision and you got to have blinders on
and not to see anything that is on the
left man right side and just really
focus and what they call in golf and in
tennis and elders ball sports
keep your eye on the ball and when you
do that when you focus that much on
something then of course you are not
being able to enjoy all the things that
life has to offer because you're so
focused on this one thing I remember
that when I started with bodybuilding
and with weight lifting one of the first
things that order was because I come
from a country where you ski and the
skiing is very popular don't go skiing
you know you can't go skiing because
you're going to break a leg eventually
and that will set you back and you're
not going to go and be able to weight
liftin to the body building and also so
don't go skiing don't go ice skating so
you always kind of you know have to turn
down certain things and and and you see
is there but you you have to focus on
the thing that you really want to be the
best at and that's what I did and you
know I don't regret that at all because
you cannot be losing everything and you
cannot do everything and at the same
time for your champion in one thing
there is no such thing so I decided I
want to be a champion I decided that I
wanted to go all out in my various
different careers in bodybuilding
if you
acting I remember that in acting it is a
perfect example whenever you sign on to
a movie let's say the Terminator or
command or predator or whatever it is
you had to sign for the insurance in the
bonding company it's a sign that you are
not going to while you're doing the
movie to any motorcycle riding any
skiing no horseback riding the barrel
shooting the scuba diving and all of
those things because those things are
dangerous
and they don't want you to get into
those dangers while you're shooting a
movie because you know when you get
injured then the holdup and the whole
production costs millions and millions
of dollars so it just shows you if to
make sacrifices yes you can be
determined that yes he can be the
commander yes you give me the last
action here and order things but you
cannot do those kind of things while
you're doing the movie so you always
have to make sacrifices that's just the
bottom line of it so this is why you
believe in having a specific goal so
that you have an endpoint when then you
can say okay the movie is finished now I
can go skiing well I started skiing with
the age of 30 after was finished with
composition and then I was not allowed
the skis like I said during the times
when I was doing a movie which I totally
understood it was hard to do because I'm
very much into skiing and love skiing
because I missed out on it when I was
young and now I love doing it on
motorcycle riding and all of a sudden I
cannot ride the motorcycle for the three
months while I'm doing a movie so so you
have to you have to make sacrifices and
you know but that's that's difference
between being a kid and being grown up
as a kid you always want to have
everything so growing up you have to
make choices and I made the right choice
and I'm happy as I made the choice it
may remind you because you just
mentioned something about you got the
shoot for your call not everyone is as
driven as I am I want to make this
perfectly clear I was always a very
driven person I grew up to driven I
think it's because I came from a little
country and it was after the Second
World War there was poverty and
starvation and there was not much around
and you are poor and
other stuff so it creates an a whole
different fire in a belly and the will
to succeed and all the stuff and I just
had that but that was my thing I was
into that not everyone is as driven and
then you don't have to be the driven the
people that are very happy with a normal
job to have a wonderful family and it
just relax and to live a moderate and to
good life and that's what makes them
happy the key thing is to recognize this
many roads as being successful and many
roads to be happy and the ultimate goal
that people always should shoot for is
that they're satisfied that they're
happy and that can come many different
ways
Michael Denari says he seem that Warren
Buffett will be one of their advisers
and an upcoming episode of The
Apprentice how did you get to know
Warren by what Warren Buffett has become
a friend of mine I would say for decades
now we used to travel around and end up
at the same places and you know he asked
me several times to come with him and
maybe does his business presentations
and stuff like that and he and I hit it
off really well then he bought net shed
because actually around a lot of it
there with different sheds for the movie
promotions and all that kind of stuff
so we really got to you know like each
other
and I of course had the highest respect
for him because here's a guy that is so
rich and makes so much money and is so
successful with so many companies but
he's not really in the money this is the
wildest thing I mean he's late he stayed
in normal hotel rooms and he drives
around when you go to Omaha with a
regular car that he's been driving
around with for the last 30 years and
you know if any he just isn't into it so
that is really funded for him it's just
kind of like you know being like the
greatest athlete or being like you know
an astronaut oh well that happens to be
his back and he's very very talented to
make $1.00 in the two and he's a
wonderful human being the most giving
human being as you know that he in his
will he's going to give away all of his
money afterwards so it gives a little
bit
the recipes gives a way to chair it and
all this kind of to me that he is a
extraordinary human being and so he was
also one of the first ones when I ran
for governor
- he's a Democrat I'm a Republican but
he stood by my side because he knew
where my heart was that I was interested
in serving all the people not to be an
ideology in this ideology get you know
caught up in this idea logical corners
of also on that you know he was there he
endorsed me and he was standing on my
left I remember the press conference and
George Shultz secretary Churchill stood
on my right side and both of them
endorsement that gives kind of the
message that I want to deserve all
people of California Democrats and
Republicans and everybody and so so he
was also supportive and I you know asked
him I said I'm doing the Celebrity
Apprentice can it be one of my advisers
he immediately said honor anything you
want anything you need any of my
products that we promoted to set up a
certain kind of a task which then we
ended up doing so he is a wonderful
human being in the great great friend
Demirel II says the current state of
modern bodybuilding versus Arnold's time
what's your personal opinion on modern
bodybuilding and your thoughts on
steroid use if it's ever appropriate if
steroids a performance-enhancing drug
then I think Congress right now should
take it immediately okay so that's
number one number two I think when you
talk about bodybuilding it's always
important that we think about is it the
competitive world of bodybuilding are we
talking about in general bodybuilding
which means building the body through
weight resistance let's talk first about
two that the one for the ordinary people
that are not interested in competing I
think that the sport and the activity of
bodybuilding has exploded in the last 40
years I remember that when I started out
people had a very negative attitude
about bodybuilding and they thought that
he will get muscle-bound
and they saw that you
I'm gay and you will be stupid and say
you will become a narcissist hanging out
in front of the mirror all the time and
all those kind of things think that it
is paid for your health doctors were
warning don't do this and coaches were
wanting for athletes not to pick up any
weights that you will get muscle-bound
and it will you know reduce your
performance you get stiff and all this
stuff so that all has changed now you go
40 years forward
and in this 40 years we have seen out
that weight resistance training is it
totally accepted and it's one of the
number-one activities in the world I
mean even now in hospitals where doctors
say this is the worst thing for your
health now when you have hospitals that
have rehab rooms and facilities with
weight machines resistance machines and
dumbbells and barbells and plates and
pulleys and all kinds of things because
they know this is the best way to
recover and to come back as quickly as
possible after injury or after surgery
and so on and the same thing is in
athletics there is not one single
athlete that doesn't work out with
weights if it is boxers you have C
fighters if it is in the power lifters
of this golfers with his tennis players
football players every football team has
a huge astrayed rooms every basketball
team s weight rooms every university has
weight facilities every high school is
great facilities every military base did
you go this I mean I travel around and
visit the military bases around the
world there's hundreds of different
benchpress benches and you know squat
racks and heavy weights and machines and
everything for people so that men and
women can train day and night in the
gymnasium and get ready for those
battles and for those very risky kind of
things that they do that very very
dangerous so they want every month to be
in shape and they know that the ultimate
shape you get when you also include
weight training in your in your daily
training so to me it is fantastic we
have seen the changes every hotel now
when you travel around the world has all
the weight for all the weight facilities
and when it comes to the competitive
sport of bodybuilding I have to say that
there were huge progress there was huge
progress made when I was competing it
was like 30 countries that had regular
annual bodybuilding competitions now
there's a hundred and ninety two
countries that hold endor bodybuilding
competitions in the national
competitions and orders so that has
grown also and the only thing that
bothers me is the way we developed in
professional bodybuilding the idea of
body now has changed so much the guys
that are winning the day not looking
anymore the way the ideal body was where
people really admired and said I want to
look like this nowadays duf guys to the
510 tall at all and that weighs 300
pounds they look more kind of like
muscular power lifters on stage a lot of
times then bodybuilders or people that
have really an attractive be shape
beautiful body so we got away from that
and of course this is my opinion now cuz
others that feel differently about that
and but this is a debate that we've been
having now for the last ten years in
bodybuilding how do we bring it back
again and really idolized and make the
winners look more attractive where they
don't have this big belly sticking out
where they don't have this kind of Block
in kind of physics but to have a more
athletic in them work kind of a thin
waist wide shoulders and do have the
biceps be the same measurement as the
calves in those the next is the way it
used to be people in the old days when
they saw a picture of Steve Reeves they
said I want to look like that or if you
saw a picture of John Grimek who won mr.
universe in 1948 I think it was he was a
fantastic poser he was he did acrobatics
handstands Norris he was also
extraordinary weightlifter he could do
muscle control people wanted to be John
Grimek so that is really the ideal thing
and I think that eventually we have to
get back to that again of course the
bodies have developed the techniques
have developed food supplements have
developed machines have developed to the
bodies up bigger and better than they
were then but
doesn't mean that we have to have you
know people look like monsters on the
stage I think this should have a much
more appealing body and that's why I
think in bodybuilding we have now
created other categories which is you
know mr. fitness and mr. natural and mr.
vision is that to get away from this
kind of block you look but bodybuilding
is is you know is booming and a lot of
more people than ever are doing it a
manba Drouin says how do you think about
risk
how would you train have you trained
yourself to take better risks and
increase your risk appetite
[Music]
well I think that risk shouldn't be the
goal how do you take more risk the goal
should be that you envision your goal
that you set a really high goal and the
only way you can set a high goal is if
you are not afraid of failure you have
to take risks I mean the bottom line is
is that I mean when I think the amount
of risks that I took to be where I am
today and it was very risky to say that
I'm going to be the bodybuilding
champion of the world in a country where
skiing was really the national sport or
bicycling in Suffragette but you are not
bodybuilding or weightlifting and so the
Greece culture for me to ever go to come
to market was a risk to do go and say
you know that I'm going to get into
movie business but let's just to get
into the movie business but to become a
leading man or the run for governor of
this I was able to just go and say you
know no matter what it takes and yes I
may fail but I'm gonna go and take that
risk and go for it and and and and you
know when you the more risks you said
you take the higher the reward is on the
end I mean just look at in the financial
world I mean if you make an investment
that is has no risk at all you invest in
Pontus I mean like that there's very
little return or we put the money in the
bank if you're lucky you get 2% the
interest but if you take an investment
that is risky then of course the risk
could be that it fails but the upside is
much much greater so I am always the
type of a person that is willing to take
risk and I think that the key thing to
success is not to be afraid of failure
as I said earlier that if you fail
what's the worst that can happen there
you go and you get up and you do it
again and you try the game and you try
it again there's no one to subsidence
what differentiates the winner from the
losers is it earlier in the people that
get up are the ones that are the winners
and so don't be afraid of taking risks
don't be afraid of failing because that
would just make you freeze up and you're
never going to accomplish anything so be
free
and just relax and just go and say that
this is what life is all about about is
taking risk and go and set big scores
and go for it end of story
do you think a lot of your risk appetite
came from things you learned in the gym
what it was not that I had a risk
appetite
it was just together learned from sports
that you've got to be able to take risk
and you got to be it should not be
afraid of failing when you go to the the
when your weight lifter and you have in
front of you let's say 315 pounds I
remember was this young kid were lifting
weight and then you put on the weight
after the second lift for the third lift
you always put on the weight that you've
never lifted before so automatically you
know that there's a 50/50 chance or
whatever it is the percentage that
you're going to fail but and this is in
front of people so they're in sports
there is no embarrassment they're there
when you fail it's understood stages
like as I said about the baseball player
but Ted Williams what it is you you you
would not be able to do always
everything successful so baked us if I
took the risk to lift the weights that
have never lifted and to give it a shot
you have to approach the weights with a
positive attitude and think about I'm
going to do it but there's so chance
that you're not doing it but this does
not make me stop and not put that weight
on because it's the only way you're
going to go and grow and get better and
they'll really an eye on how much you
can accomplish how much you can lift and
so on and that's why it's a lesson that
you learn in sports and it's a lesson
that is good for the rest of your life
and everything you do if it is movies if
it is business if it's investments if it
is in politics you got to take risk
aditya Sinha says how do you stay
motivated to keep working on your goals
and how do you not run out of juice
well again it goes back to the vision I
think that if you have a very clear
vision of where you want to go you
always will be motivated because I
remember that when I got in from when I
decided that I'm going to retire from
bodybuilding competition
and I'm going to get into acting I mean
it was such a great vision and I thought
about Clint Eastwood I'm going to be
another Clint Eastwood I want to be like
another child's bronson this were my
idols I'm going to be like Warren Beatty
I want to be like those guys that
they're making a million dollars that
was in the 70s now they made a million
dollars in moving in same as if I'll can
you imagine of working your way after
that to meet that vision was just so
wonderful that I did everything that I
could to get there and I was like
working on you know my English I was
working on my speech and the enunciation
I was taking acting classes I was doing
everything that I could
improv classes and other stuff and I
really worked my way by hard work worked
my way up and slowly became you know one
of the top leading man and so that is I
think did everything like that it's it's
you get motivated by your vision I
remember you know just with the
environment we talked about earlier I
really envisioned a world that
eventually will be clean and we will get
rid of fossil fuels and so to me that
vision motivates me to go out and to
speak about the environment to travel
around the world and to speak about
environment to use my USC Schwarzenegger
Institute and to go and promote a clean
environment and all those things so it's
kind of the vision that motivated so I
don't run out of choose because of that
because you know there is nothing to do
with age at all it's always big new
goals and they then go after those goals
and that's what motivates you and it's
what makes it exciting
it's what makes you passionate about it
Christian gray says what specific things
that you look for in your real estate
investments Oh
one dollar in the two there was the
number one goal and the number to call
was is that it has to be interesting I
didn't like to invest just enroll ante
to sit on it and two solid five years
later for profit to me that was not
exciting what was exciting was is to buy
Roland and then we draw up plans and to
go build an apartment building or to
build an office building or to build a
shopping mall and and to find the right
partners that he bring together and to
go all outfitted and I remember that you
know my first investment it was back in
1974 I saved up $27,000 from doing
seminars and exhibitions and all kinds
of things as a mail-order business I did
pre-clearing jobs and dollar after
dollar I saved up until I had $27,000
and have to say that to people
understand the body building even though
in 1974 I was already a multi than mr.
Olympian mr. universe five times in mr.
world and all those things but in
bodybuilding there was no money at this
point so I had to do it the
old-fashioned way
I had to confirm it had to go to work
and to do it and I saved up $27,000
found an apartment building a six unit
apartment building in Santa Monica
north of Wilshire Boulevard which was
very important to be dwarfed worship all
of us good area and I bought it for two
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars and
they needed thirty seven thousand
dollars down so I went to Joe Weider the
man that was sent the king of the
bodybuilding Empire and profit America
and he gave me $10,000 it was kind of a
third feed on this thing and I paid him
back within the year
but they had to $37,000 together at the
apartment building and then two and a
half years later we sold it for three
hundred and sixty five thousand dollars
and so imagine the profit from 215 to
365 in two and a half years and I only
put like 37 down so so there is a huge
huge profit and I remember that a
fountain a 12 unit apartment building
and we then sorted the six units
then roll the money over bought the 12
unit one and then the next one was a 36
unit and it got bigger and bigger and
then I had apartments all over the place
instead of there you know building
office buildings and shopping malls in
Suffolk that so it really to me the key
thing is that it's fun that is
challenging that you go and map it out
that you find out when you get into an
area and you buy a property that what
kind of a apartments to the need what
kind of sizes in its region is the two
units in this area or just one unit and
what kind of shops do you want to have
downstairs in your office building what
kind of a look who do you want to
attract so to me that whole thing was
really a lot of fun just so we're a
hundred percent clear did you buy the
six unit apartment building before you'd
ever bought a house do me it is much
more important when you buy your first
real estate to buy a rental apartment
this is an income property because I had
the front unit in this apartment
building which we called the owners unit
it was 2,400 square feet which was
plenty for me at that time upstairs
downstairs and there was five units in
the back and it was a great great
investment but I would not go and buy a
house first before I buy income property
so to me that was the important thing
that would always recommend to people to
buy first the income property and to go
and make it a good investment and one
should realize when it comes to real
estate if you invest wisely and if it is
in a good area and stuff like that and
it's a growing area it's never called
spending money there's a difference
between spending money and investing
money in real estate you invest because
the money it goes up the value goes up
in most cases and when you buy furniture
that's spending money because as soon as
you take the furniture out of the
furniture shop you loser automatically
right off the top 30% you know that
spending money you will never get that
money back so you were talking earlier
about the raw land about your worst
investment if it's super
like airport that never happened in when
I explained that one well that's why I
said Roland is not really in a fun thing
to do to invest him I invested in that
my first investment when they came to
America was in Roland but I invested in
that because it was in Palmdale
Lancaster area and there there was very
well known that everyone wrote about it
that they're going to build a supersonic
Airport and the Dead was the future to
move away from the Los Angeles Airport
and to move and then create a new giant
Airport for supersonic planes and then
they outlawed supersonic planes and the
airport was never built and so now I
still own the property but even this
five thousand dollar property that I
bought then now is worth six hundred and
eighty thousand dollars so I cannot call
this a loss this is something that my
kids will inherit it would have a good
time and can sell it and have some money
so it's all right now in the meantime
they've put streets in there and
electricity and and you know eventually
the area will be built up but it does
definitely not going to be a supersonic
Airport Jerry Potter says if you are
allowed to make one law remove one law
or amend one law in this country which
law would you choose and why
well images say the obvious law is I
think what this question is referring to
is would I like to change the law so
that a foreign-born can also run for
president yes of course that would
create good law but besides that that's
an obvious one that's a that's a
no-brainer
but I mean the other law I think will be
really interesting that is if the
legislature and the lawmakers in
Washington do not perform and really
down solves the kind of critical
problems with immigration reform if it
is environmental in activities where we
really shoot for in the 40 or 50 percent
of renewable energy and reduce our
greenhouse gases per certain percentage
in the next 10 years or so if we don't
accomplish those things though the
infrastructure and all that they all
should be voted out of office I think we
should start all over again because
I think how long can America hang there
with no action how many decades now have
we talked about that we need to build
our infrastructure that we have now so
many more cars on the road therefore we
need to build more highways and freeways
and we need to build high-speed rail all
over the country we need to build out
our airports so that when you arrive
goes here but they don't look some of
them like third world country airports
and stuff like that we need to build
more dams above water storage I mean
they in California for instance I mean
it's a it's a dreadful when you talk
about the drought and then in fact
really it just means that we have not
built a infrastructure to capture the
water when it rains and then have it
when there is a drought and stuff like
this I think the legislators the
lawmakers have to perform for the people
that's why they're there it costs us in
the two and a half billion dollars to do
to have them down Capitol and so they
got to perform and they got to recognize
the fact that not one party can solve
the problem that you the wages to
scientists that Democrats and
Republicans must work together there's
no law can you know sustain for a long
period of time if it's just dumped at
one party or the other both of the
parties you know we see now with
Obamacare I mean where it was only done
by Democrats and now it's going to get
undone or you know executive orders that
are just going to be thrown out that the
next president always so that is not
really a solution the solution is if
these Democrats and Republicans work
together even though this is very
difficult to do but that's why they are
going to Washington to take on this very
difficult task and look I had to work
together remember California was an
overwhelming amount of Democratic
legislators and I had to work with them
I was surrounded by a Democratic
Lieutenant Governor a democratic
treasurer controller you know the head
of education everyone was the Attorney
General everyone was a Democrat and
somehow I made it work so at least 50%
of all the things that I wanted to do I
got done and then some things we failed
but that means that the bottom line is
is they must
work for the people and they got to get
back together otherwise this should be a
law that they will get voted out of
office so they have to show the
accomplishments or they'll go there
they'll go home and someone would say
what that's why we have elections every
four years that's why we have elections
for Congress every two years in this
Maties but that's not the way it works
because they all go home is as well I
did really well but the others you know
but it's inexcusable that Congress is
like a 14 to 15 percent approval rating
I mean that's worse than the approval
rating of Fidel Castro of AIDS or
something like that I mean what the hell
are we talking about here so let's get
our act together to potentially stay
active some smart people in Washington
Democrats and Republicans are like they
should work together and do something
that is really good for the country
and you're talking about getting them to
actually work together it sounds like
maybe we need a law that they have to
schmooze together like you did in a
cigar time what remember they say we
cannot do things just all the way on the
right order on the Left I believe of
what Eisenhower said President
Eisenhower said you know always that
politics is like the road you know the
left and the right is pagada and the
center is drivable and that's exactly
the ways in politics is if you gotta be
innocent it cannot be an extremist to
the left of the derive David Paulette
says how did you drum up business when
you owned that construction company with
Franco Colomba well the important thing
was dead Franco Columbu who was my
training partner for the last 50 years
and very very dear friend and he was a
bricklayer and so because in
bodybuilding we didn't make any money so
we decided that we're going to go and
start a little little small brick laying
business where we go to people's homes
and we fix up things to the broken and
we were very fortunate because we
started the business and got our license
business license and went to the IRS and
told them about the company does it the
taxes that we're going to have to pay
and all this kind of thing in organized
orders and then we went out instead of
working and we started getting jobs into
the build walls and patios and
fireplaces notice' and then all of a
sudden the earthquake happened
in 1971 and there was a massive
earthquake that just wiped out a lot of
things and so we got from one day to the
next like hundreds of phone calls to
come and to give estimates and to go and
to rebuild the patios and the walls and
fireplaces and chimneys and all kinds of
things so we literally had to hire other
people from the gym body builders from
the gym and all of a sudden we had this
whole workforce and decided to go to
work and we made great money I mean not
great great money but I mean good money
from for those days and we could save
some money and buy our protein powders
and and were able to eat you know great
into the steaks and then have our
protein shakes and eggs and the best
foods and all the stuff they be needed
and so I you know we had a very
successful business and it was the
greatest thing that the most fun doing
those kind of things and we just put a
little ad in the LA Times I remember in
bed ad produced you know really great
great action for us was in the handset
the ad just basically said European
bricklayers and masonry workers and
stone experts you know because people
are be realized very quickly that the
American people loved when you get you
know kind of rook from other countries
and they love to mention Swedish massage
if it will give America massage even so
as well as when is a Swedish massage
Oh Japanese massage or European
bricklayer or a German car in a mechanic
or something like that with the I
remember when I came over and there's
someone said the mrs. green car down
there to Lincoln Boulevard he said
there's a little garage there's a German
mechanic I mean that guy is so good
maybe you know I went down there got my
house and it was not any better than
American you know mechanic but I mean
people just love the European or some
other foreign kind of a country and so
we use that European bricklayer and
stone work and that you have been you
know experts in all those kind of
languages and it worked
landing chip franks and this is our last
question says could you take tim ferriss
in a one-on-one fight right now if so
how long would it take well first of all
easy
you seem fair as even though he disses
to Jitsu and stuff like that and he's in
fantastic shape but I'm a machine
forget that and blast let's also not
forget he cannot hit me because he will
be elderly abuse
so therefore I would just grab him and I
would just put the finish him off with a
5 minute kind of a routine and then an
answer say hasta la vista baby
do you have any closing advice for his
letters well first of all I think this
is one of the best podcast because they
are always interesting they are always
exciting every time you listen to his
podcast you learn and I think this was
all about we got to always learn and
listen to interesting material because I
think this is always the challenge and
he being that he's such a hungry guy
that always also wants to learn
he is so motivated to go and to put out
information and like his latest book you
know what what makes you successful what
are that kind of a little tricks that
successful people use in order to so
he's always educating everybody that's
what I like about it
hey guys this is Tim again a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me and would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday's a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favourite
new albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that have somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by at
Green's I've used that but agreeance for
many many years and I'm asked all the
time if you could use only one
supplement what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is my all in one nutritional
insurance at least that's how I think
about it it is much more than greens
it's a complete whole food supplement
with 75 or so ingredients packed into
one tablespoon per day so when I travel
for instance of course I would like to
follow all of my regimens all of my
pills all of my self involved my food to
the tea but sometimes circumstances
intervene and you're too busy or things
you're too hectic this helps me to
mitigate the likelihood of getting sick
and to perform optimally so if I go to
say South America for an AcroYoga
intensive which I did in Colombia at one
point I was running around like a
chicken with its head cut off and I took
this every morning and it is extremely
extremely helpful and I usually travel
with travel packets among other things
so you should try it out is the short
version of this as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive $100 worth
of travel packs for free when you order
that's 20 free additional individual
travel pouches when you order simply go
to athletic greens comm forward slash
Tim to check it out so take a look at
what it greens.com
forward slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by wealthfront and this
is a very unique sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
run so the question is why why is it so
popular why is it unique because you can
get services previously reserved for the
ultra wealthy but only pay pennies on
the dollar for them and this is because
they use smarter software instead of
retail locations bloated sales teams etc
and I'll come back to that in a second I
suggest you check out wealthfront com
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they put you
in and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that
as I would you can set it and forget it
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than ten asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned some confusing software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15 thousand which is managed
for free if you use my link Welkom
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of FCC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth funds that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money which
for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listeners you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
dot-com for flush Tim fast free there's
no downside that I can think of
you